this is a production of Cornell
University Cornell oh yeah when I was a
graduate student I was very much aware
of group led by Ed lemon here Musgraves
doing photosynthesis research sort of
moving from the laboratory skater's
reductionist approach to photosynthesis
out into the field and you know there's
you know iconic paper Suns work in it's
a corn field that was maybe 1965
something like that science just so it's
always been I've always been interested
in Cornell I've never visited here
before so it's been it's good to be here
I
and it's good to to experience the
legendary winter I was very lucky to get
here but with Young's help we made it
and made this work so I'm interested as
it says in photosynthesis and what I'm
trying to do is to patch together ways
to model and measure photosynthesis at
large scales while not forgetting the
mechanisms that underlie it so I'm
trying to make the connections the
long-term goal is really to come up with
a way of monitoring photosynthesis to
understand what controls it and
particularly to see whether things like
climate change are changing it land-use
change how are we doing in agriculture
and things like this the photosynthesis
is really the primary driver of all
these productivity processes and then of
course is linked as you mentioned
transpiration and to the hydrologic
cycle and actually to weather so it's
been
a lot of fun kind of middle of all this
stuff in working with things like our
system models so I'll talk mostly today
about fluorescence which is really the
expert on and a little bit about ways
that we're trying to build on what we
learned from chlorophyll fluorescence to
understand the standard multi spectral
approaches that have been used by the
satellites that have been around since
the 1980s to see if we can improve the
way that they do photosynthesis
I start by so that I don't forget these
are the folks in the lab doing most of
the work I and this is Grayson Badgley
who's done recently work on reflectance
convert linking reflectance measurements
to the solar news fluorescence you lose
a modeller radiation transport modeler
Arie is doing the doing measurements I
sort of lab measurements working out the
techniques for major in fluorescent
fluorescence from fields Jan is a
modeler working with me on extending the
the models that we've made of
photosynthesis Lee is a is doing work on
he's a great statistician and he's
working with us on putting this together
and try and do global simulations
yuuichi is doing geostatistics trying to
show how solar news fluorescence works
as a variable driving or correlating
with gross primary productivity trying
to approach it from the data as opposed
to the modeling approach and this is you
we'll Ryu who is a sabbatic bizza tur
from from Seoul Korea and they do most
of the work so I want to make sure they
have credit to start out with I thought
I'd the way I look at it I you know it's
driven by the Sun of course but I think
it's useful to think about really how is
it linked up think of it the radiations
coming from the Sun really comes from
the collision of mostly hydrogen atoms
in the Solar solar atmosphere right at
the top and when a wonderful two
molecules or two atoms like this collide
there's a really rapid change in
velocity when that happens electrons
jump around and the a good deal of most
of the energy of that collision gets
transferred into the emission of like
romantic electromagnetic radiation and
the average energy of those is coupled
to the temperature the Sun is about
6,000 K so and that's the mechanism that
some the energy produced by that
thermonuclear reactions get released at
the surface it's just blackbody
radiation so every photon that comes out
is really related to the collision of
atoms on the Sun some of those photons
get earth and some fairly large fraction
of them actually wind up getting
absorbed by chlorophyll if they're in
the right wavelengths so it's eight
minutes from the Sun to the chlorophyll
the electron is promoted to a higher
energy orbital in the chlorophyll
molecule and basically it has the energy
of this collision that happened just
shortly ago and in
relative listing terms simultaneously on
the Sun so in a way a part of that
molecule is at 6,000 K weight huh
could do a lot and it of course is
unstable in this configuration but it
has trapped at least momentarily the
energy and what it's done is essentially
promoted that electron on chlorophyll
molecule to a higher state as you know
the the blue absorption of chlorophyll
degrades to the red first excited state
and it can decay or move to other other
decay by fluorescence or photochemistry
or other pathways basically these are
what I'm going to use fee for is a
fluorescence or a yield and the yield of
all the processes that can be involved
in the the excitation of that absorbed
packet of energy as up to one in terms
of sort of structural biology someplace
that this is the a diagram of the yeah
kind of a symbolic diagram of the of a
photosystem two reaction center and
antenna complex where the reaction there
two reaction centers here in the in this
center and these are light harvesting
chlorophyll proteins which are the ones
that are most likely to capture that
energy the energy is captured and moves
from chlorophyll molecule to chlorophyll
molecule and ultimately comes to the the
reaction center or something else
happens to it but it becomes the
reaction center there's a charge
separation that occurs and the energy is
in electronic state many so I just kind
of diagrammatically it looks like this
the energy is comes in and the real
transformative element in this is -
chlorophyll molecules that are really
oppressed close to one another and when
they're far they're apart they just set
the and transfer energy as
electromagnetic energy from one to
another but when they're really close
together they they can interact in a way
that where an electron moves from one
excited chlorophyll one chlorophyll to
the other so it it's a charge separation
and I when that charge separation occurs
an electron can be provided from water
to quench the one that's become positive
and the one that has the electron on it
can move that electron over to a quinone
and ultimately to a mobile electron
transport carrier which diffuses away
the essence of this is that what started
out as an electromagnetic excitation
winds up causing an electronic charge
separation which is a kind of a redox
reaction and the energy of that is
essentially stored in the the product
here a reduced de fusible chemical
entity so the chemin so what started in
the Sun with a collision winds up out
here you know eight minutes and maybe a
few hundred picoseconds as a stable
chemic chemical entity which has enough
energy associated with it to fix carbon
dioxide and power of the biosphere it's
not really fundamentally different than
what we
with a silicon photocell where the
photocell the photoelectric effect in
silicon causes charge separations and
these migrate to electrodes and current
flows which we conserve kind of store
that in a battery and we can drive
around on it all right so I tend to look
at what's happening with photosynthesis
very much in the same way that we're
using solar energy to talk to to
generate a or charge a chemical battery
and we can then use what's in that
battery which is in the form of reduced
carbon compounds and oxygen
metabolically to go over run or
industrially to burn fossil fuels to
generate electricity or power cars or
whatever so all of that really goes back
to charging this large battery which is
last year just by say probably one of
the best indicators of this is the
oxygen in the atmosphere it's about it
takes about fifteen hundred years or
half of the oxygen to be processed by
redox reactions that are associated with
this battery turning over so there's you
can see it's pretty active we kind of
tend to think of oxygen as being stable
and always there but in timeframes so to
say between the last ice age and now the
atmosphere is probably all new oxygen
that's just kind of why I'm fascinating
the thousands
you mentioned the stuff that we did a
long time ago in 1980 well in 1980 or so
on photosynthesis
modeling this is a picture that we I
just was at a symposium with this is
Graham Farquhar Suzanne Eve on camera
and B we did a paper that Graham
actually got the Kyoto Prize in part for
so I thought I'd just throw that out
because we were all in our 30s or 20s at
the time that was done and it's kind of
funny to think that's stuff you're doing
as a postdoc actually something sticks
and something happens we had no idea
that this was in fact we had entirely
different goals for doing the work and
it was rejected three times but it's
turned out to be reason it was with
potion planet it's the most cited paper
that plant is published but it took us I
think three years to get it accepted
just to decide the the whole idea of it
is to deal with this problem that
photochemistry is coming in at whatever
rate the light comes in so the potential
from a photochemistry is entirely
dependent on clouds and solar angle and
things like that and leaves in between
your particular chloroplast and the Sun
and the the energy is going to be stored
ultimately in dark reactions which
result in co2 fixation and Simpsons
Insulza sugars which is dependent upon
the availability of co2 linked to the
availability of water temperature and
the amount of nutrients that are in that
the plant has to make enzymes with so
this has an entirely different drummer
than this but there's no place to put
excess photochemical products so you've
got to have a way to make
this system stay balanced so that the
rate at which this occurs and this
occurs are balanced because there's
there's there's very little capacity for
storage in between the two and that was
the very simple idea that led to this
paper that the minimum of the rate of
photosynthesis is a minimum of the
capacity of either one of these
reactions a lot of the work we're doing
right now really focuses back to well
how does this actually fit together what
what is that what is the mechanism that
allows this one to go at its maximum
capacity until it reaches this one and
then this one to go in its capacity
while this one sees it without large
losses between the two and sorry for the
scribbling slide here but the idea we're
working on right now with Jen Johnson is
- is that the real regulation of this is
a a cytochrome complex that sits between
photosystem 1 and photosystem two
photosystem two is the one that
generates oxygen produces an electron
which moves to the cytochrome and then
moves on to the photosystem 1 which
lifts it up to the level where it can
react protists react in carbon fixation
I the interesting thing is that when
this system becomes light saturated this
reaction center becomes more reduced and
this reaction center becomes more
oxidized you'd think that both of them
would become more reduced and the reason
that they doesn't work that way is that
this is kind of a ratchet or a regulator
that occurs right in between and that
there is very strong regulation at this
point which prevents if for example you
buy a bright too bright a light
for photosynthesis it prevents this one
from becoming too reduced and producing
really strong reactive substrates so it
just kind of keeps the voltage across
this whole system more or less constant
while still allowing things to work so
it's it's kind of a it's a kind of a
conductor in this and so I guess I tell
you this because we keep working on
things like this while we're working on
large-scale photosynthesis studies
because they keep exposing things that
we didn't understand about the
photosynthetic mechanism it's kind of
fun to go back and play with them one of
the reasons that we got very interested
in photosynthesis which was related to
this yield here or fluorescence excuse
me this is the yield of fluorescence so
fractional yield of fluorescence it's
it's a fairly small component but it's
maybe 1% to 5% of all the photons that
come in are readmitted as fluorescence
the interesting thing is that that's a
function of the molecule itself of
chlorophyll it's like when it's excited
it has a half time or a half life just
like a radioactive half-life it's going
to decay just as a function of the time
but the exit excited state exists so it
tells you something about all the rest
of these things that are going on at
least the some of them if these didn't
exist then the lifetime of fluorescence
would be very long and you would
approach a yield of one so it gives you
kind of an internal clock to understand
how photosynthesis is processing the
photons make sense feel free to
interrupt please so
fluorescence is also something that we
can major outside of the chloroplast so
it's we can then see what's going on in
the leaf by just looking at the
fluorescence that's coming out of it
and it's been used for 50 years or more
to look at photosynthesis one of the
really nice things
nice approaches for looking at
photosynthesis particularly in
laboratory situations the other thing
that I wanted to point out here is that
some of these are passive that is
there's kind of a wastage term and
fluorescence which have to do simply
with a lifetime and then some of them
are dynamic that deal are essentially
physiologically controlled and vary with
the system so we can see how these
dynamic components are behaving by
following fluorescence and those dynamic
components are photochemistry itself and
a regulated step or regulated competing
reaction we call non photochemical
quenching which is actually kind of like
Stowe mates for life it regulates the
amount of light that comes through from
the pigment system of the reaction
centers so in essence that problem of
how light is just how the light
reactions are down regulated starts
before the photons even get the reaction
center they're quenched by this non
photochemical quenching negative how
much to go into this is we have we can
measure fluorescence and we can measure
photosynthesis this is a gas exchange
cuvette or a system which can measure
the co2 and water vapor exchange of a
plant and it also has the capability of
measuring fluorescence changes in
response to chain
changing the light environment and we
can calculate the yield of
photochemistry
in this system by saying the Weller's
for electrons required for every co2
that's for photons required for every
co2 that's fixed and there is a we can
measure the co2 exchange add to it the
dark respiration that's going on correct
for the photo respiratory effect and
divided by the total number of quanta
and that gets you that this is the
number of electrons that are transported
to account for the photosynthetic rate
that's majored and this is a number of
photons that are absorbed by that system
so that gives you the apparent quantum
yield or for a photochemical yield of
that system with the fluorescence by
looking at the change in fluorescence
you get by applying an intense light you
can get an estimate directly of the
photochemistry
it comes about by making the assumption
that when you apply an intense light you
essentially reduce all the reaction
centers so that there are no
photochemistry stops and fluorescence is
going to increase because photochemistry
has stopped these measurements are
actually measurements of the yield not
the actual amount of fluorescence the
actual amount of fluorescence goes way
up when you hit it with a bright light
but if you use a special technique which
uses a modulated fluorescent light or
modulated light to excite fluorescence
and then you look at only the modulated
component of fluorescence you see that
yield effect and here the ratio the
amount of fluorescence increase that is
this variable fluorescence that occurs
relative to the total modulation the
total fluorescence that occurs this is
the dark this is the fluorescence that
occur
steady-state this is what you get to
bright light that that ratio is actually
the photochemistry
the efficiency of photochemistry and
there are ways you can go through and
count and prove that the interesting
thing is that if you turn the light on
allow the system to equilibrate and then
redo this bright light you don't get
near as much fluorescence out and this
ratio is much lower and that's because
the photochemical yield has decreased
because the system is responding to the
increased light that you've applied to
the system it's down regulated it ah the
other interesting thing about that is if
you look at it from fluorescence or from
co2 exchange and you just take a bunch
of points and calculate the yield of
photochemistry from the two approaches
they agree pretty well so it's a gives
you a pretty strong indication that
eight you can measure photosynthesis
either by looking at the way the photons
are processed or by looking at the end
result of that processing see you - I
[Music]
think I'll just skip over this that the
main point of this is that there's no
tusen - has a whole series of regulatory
processes to drive it some of them are
very quick some of them take long
periods of time and it's kind of very
much like a current regulating IC
responding to things that are happening
downstream we can as I mentioned there's
this light stomata for light that is non
photochemical quenching and this would
be the rate constant for that non
photochemical process and this the rate
constant for the photochemical process
and this these data on this side are
derived from this experiment here this
normal graph here so this is the rate of
co2 uptake and this is the concentration
of co2 and of course as you increase the
co2 it goes up and up to fairly high
rate and then it saturates at co2 co2
saturation here you'd actually improve
this rate by giving it more light here
you can't this it's limited by the
capacity of the co2 fixing enzyme which
is co2 so out here it's a high rate this
is the rate of photosynthesis so this is
this point in this point this here and
this here correspond to one another
photochemistry is the rate of the rate
constant for motor chemistry is really
high the rate constant for non
photochemical quenching is really low
and as the this begins to to go down in
photosynthetic rate this non
photochemical quenching turns on and it
corresponds to fairly stable region
where the photochemical rate constant
stays the same or about the same so the
system is responding in such a way that
the light coming in or the photons
getting into the reaction centers are
not there they're being reduced and the
rate constant photochemistry is staying
about the same and then that system
saturates ultimately and the rate
constant photochemistry also drops as
the reaction centers close so it just to
give you an idea how that teeter-totter
kind of thing that I Illustrated to
begin with I works and this is there's a
lot of power in you doing fluorescence
but the guess the main thing that point
out here is that this Pam floor imagery
the approach that we're using to make
all these inferences about the way
photons process requires that we
manipulate the light and that's not on
if we're looking at the planet or even a
field any as we get out in the field
that's that's just not possible
so we had this great method but we were
very frustrated with the idea that he
we're never going to really apply this
in the field we did some things like put
together laser excitation systems to do
that try and pull this out but you know
you actually can't make a laser that is
in the visible range that's any brighter
than a pointer and in fact if you
actually went back and tried to license
with the laser licensing regulations a
one of these pointers I you probably
have to reduce most of their
considerably these are kind of
grandfathered in so there's not much we
can do to go out in the field and
provide bright light to manipulate so we
more or less given up that it couldn't
be used for regional or global scales
even though it's and that all changed in
about 2010 for me I was walking around a
meeting the poster session of a meeting
kind of at the close of the meeting
looking at posters that had nothing to
do with me and I stumbled on this poster
that said hey we can major fluorescence
from space and yeah I wrote down the
name and that's got on the phone the
next day it turned out that it wasn't
actually such a new deal it had been
measured before the technique was
originally worked out in the 60 in the
70s using very narrow filters to look at
the light that comes off vegetated
surfaces
it had actually been measured I with a
reflectance satellite one of the things
that's kind of interesting about this
comparison here these are crop circles
irrigated sort patches in the desert and
you can see these are in RGB color and
these are in fluorescents and this is
really dark there's there's no light
coming off that is the light that's
coming here is the light that's coming
from from chlorophyll fluorescence and
one of the things that b-doubles remote
sensing in general if I reflect insists
there's not a lot of light reflected by
the uninteresting part of the land
surface and it's really messes things up
and here you can see that forget it
you don't see it at all if you could
just look at that you'd see the plants
much more specifically and that was the
the punchline from these two papers that
simultaneously figured out how to
acquire the fluorescence from satellites
that were originally designed to measure
the concentration of gases in the
atmosphere and this is a year's
fluorescence measurements showing that
areas like the Amazon have very and the
Indonesia and tropical Africa have the
highest rates of fluorescence and things
more or less follow the patterns that we
expect so even though we couldn't
measure do any experiments on
manipulating the light look like this is
coming out that's looking kind of like
we hoped fluorescence would look anyway
and this is a graph from a recent paper
that yang is the senior author on
looking at fluorescence from a satellite
that was originally put in orbit to
measure carbon dioxide
concentration and flux measured at co2
flux towers I simultaneously with the
fluorescence measures they agree pretty
well so this is pulling it down to a
smaller scale the other was really based
on what we expected for photosynthesis
this is really based on observations
photosynthesis so it's getting close to
home make this run here this is kind of
fun this is a yearly fluorescence
transit changes in fluorescence and if
you look the we look at it up I can make
this repeat I call your attention to the
Corn Belt here
you can see that that's really bright it
really comes up it's it's actually the
brightest spot on the planet probably by
this large spot on the planet there's
other areas that look almost as bright
the Ganges Delta area some parts of
Europe those that's what that's saying
is that photosynthesis in the Corn Belt
how about we during the time of crop
production is the highest of any place
on earth you know at least a large a
large patch this is just one of the
things that we try to do is to measure
this also from from field instruments
this is a fluorescence equivalent of a
satellite sitting above a soybean field
that we're working on this year what
we're trying to do is - this is the
absorption spectrum of chlorophyll the
green and the red is the emission
spectrum of chlorophyll fluorescence and
what we're
so light that's absorbed here comes back
some of it comes back out in these bands
and you know if we were doing this in a
laboratory we just put in a filter so
that we only use light we only only
light the plant would see light that was
in this range and then it would be dark
in this range we could see the
fluorescence from that very simple all
right that's kind of hard to do again in
the field because filtering the sunlight
doesn't work very well so it's would
require a pretty large filter to to
filter the Earth's input radiation so we
could walk walk for blocking
fluorescence but the the way we do way
that they figured out how to do this was
to look at the spectral composition of
the light that's coming down that of
course affects the spectral composition
light that's going up and wait.you
what's shown here a lot of what looks
like noise but it isn't noise it's
changes in the composition of the or the
intensity of the lights a function of
wavelength which occurs because of
things like iron and magnesium and
elements like that in the solar
atmosphere that absorb light and they
cause these little divots and you see
them again in the upwelling light
because it's essentially sunlight edge
reflecting it doesn't change its
spectral composition but fluorescence is
new light there's no impact of the fact
there's no impact of these spectral
features of the sunlight on the spectrum
of the fluorescence so if you think of
it the light that you get back out is a
function of the fluorescence coming out
and the light that's coming from the Sun
which does and if you
use a a statistical tool it's kind of
like n member unmixing you can separate
those two you can determine what
fraction of the total they're for red
light is coming back at you has come
from fluorescence and what is just
scattered light and that is made
possible by having satellites that have
the spectral resolution to resolve these
lines I we focus mostly on these lines
which we do to front offers mishit
estranja for absorptions in the solar
atmosphere this big feature is due to
oxygen in the Earth's atmosphere and a
lot of people work with this it's it's a
much bigger signal it's much easier to
separate fluorescence from photos from
scattered light using this but
unfortunately it's also due to it's due
to the oxygen atmosphere so what you see
depends upon how much of the atmosphere
is between you and your major Minh and
what's happened to the light has has
come through the atmosphere before you
actually do your measurements so it's
it's a more complicated thing but it's
possible and this is the way that we
make this this determination of how much
fluorescence there is this is always a
bit of a problematic area so if you've
got any questions about this feel free
to interrupt and ask it makes sense ok
this is just if we look at fluorescence
coming off a this is from an Amazon
canopy and all of this is due to clouds
but if we look at the fluorescence
that's coming out
it's fairly well behaved and it behaves
pretty well if we look at there are ways
that we can sort of normalize this
either to the incoming light intensity
or to the amount of light that's
reflected so it's kind of well-behaved
the measurement has is difficult
we're looking at these very small
spectral features but if we're really
careful the way we do spectroscopy
cultural temperatures do a lot of signal
averaging and things like that we get
pretty good data so yeah we got this
method based on resolving these fine
spectral details that gives us the light
emitted by chlorophyll it's a pretty
powerful proxy for photosynthesis I and
I guess the initial thought that we had
was that this would all be due to
changes in fluorescence you tell us
about the physiology the plants and that
would tell us all about photosynthesis
as we've gotten more and more involved
in this it's become clear that the
structure of the canopy that's doing
photosynthesis has an awful lot to do
with how much fluorescence gets out
maybe even more than the the yield so
and that has the really key component
here is what we call the escape
probability which is the probability
that emitted fluorescent photon that's
photons are submitted in the canopy
actually makes it out so that we could
measure it and that's very dependent
upon both the the observational geometry
so it changes as you say a satellite
looks at the surface from different
directions or if you're looking at the
same piece of canopy and the Sun were to
go through a you know the daily course
you'd also see that this emission
parameter would change so it's a
directional property of the canopy
itself just to sort of go back to that
diagram what's happening here is that
photon is absorbed in some of it gets to
the reaction center some of it since
this takes a finite period of time
chlorophyll fluorescence comes out while
it's in transit and
it tells you essentially something about
the lifetime that the photon or the
excited state has in this pigment bed
longer the lifetime the more
fluorescence is going to come out
relative to other things I think I
probably skip all this and just say that
we have we've been working to of course
one thing to do is to put this into a
model of photosynthesis and see if we
can figure out well how's that
physiology control this and this is a
series of simulations where we're
looking at photosynthetic rate as a
function of light if we change the
amount of the co2 fixing enzyme rubisco
so here is very low levels and very high
levels this has an effect on the yield
of photochemistry we've got more
capacity the ELA photochemistry can be
higher i and get some fairly complicated
patterns of the fluorescence yield as a
function of increasing decreasing to be
max and this here is the simulated Sol
reduced fluorescence you can see that
there are some differences as high
photosynthetic capacity you tend to get
more Sol reduce fluorescence than at low
photosynthetic capacity but it's known
if nowhere near the linear zero
intercept relationship which we see in
Yang's data for example and if we do
simulations with a model that
incorporates radiation transport
photosynthesis and fluorescence yield
and we very things which vary that the
near-infrared reflectance of the canopy
by changing leaf angle distribution leaf
area index fractional vegetation cover
soil color and things like that
we we change the amount of solar news
fluorescence and if we change keep go
through that same matrix of things and
change the fluorescent yield you get a
different slope so it looks like what we
see is something that's we see two
effects one is related to the
essentially structure of the canopy and
the other is related to the fluorescence
and we have the two things
simultaneously affecting what we see
from looking from space this is just to
show you something about what we expect
from the fluorescence itself based on
those models so we're looking with a
satellite at the same time of day most
of satellites we're using at polar
orbits and they come over at the same
solar time for each space so we're
always looking at the same illumination
this is say illuminated with full Sun
and lots of photosynthetic capacity this
is the photochemistry this is the non
photochemical quenching this is the sort
of wastage term and this is what's lost
by fluorescence as you go to lower
capacity the photo chemistry goes down
the non photochemistry non photochemical
quenching goes up really goes up when
you have stress but the this is the
fluorescence and this is that
fluorescence expanded ten times so this
just shows that yeah there's some
sensitivity to the environment but that
sensitivity is is not the whole story at
least we have wanted to do this to
couple with these kinds of measurements
you can measure the gas exchange of a
system we do it for time
you can measure the co2 exchange and
essentially reconstruct with the gross
primary productivity is but these are
areas that about a kilometer at most in
size and the solar it is fluorescence
measurements that we're trying to make
are normally in the range of the most
frequent one the one to use the most has
a footprint of 40 kilometers on the side
so they're too big to actually match
with these sites all right but if we
could match with these sites we have
maybe a hundred of these around the
world maybe a kilometer squared each
that's at least a sampling of one part
per million of the biosphere and that
would be useful in putting together some
information about how the whole bio
scores I think you understand that the
limitations of that as well but probably
the best approach that's been made so
far to do this is to use machine
learning to analyze these which student
in our group you in she's been doing is
to look at gas exchange in fairly large
scales air moving across the continent
and try and use models and data to
predict or to explain the variation in
the co2 concentration
you know what the co2 is it starts and
you know it at the end you should be
able to say something about what co2
change has occurred over the path across
continent the interesting thing from
this is just that the models that we
have they're sort of the state of the
art or system models get anywhere the
best one does 0.6 our point for of the
the variance and most of them are down
here in fairly low compartment
part of the variance solar dues
fluorescence by itself as a single
variable without putting in the
meteorology and a bunch of other
stuff which are in these models explains
more you can explain more of it by
putting in a couple of other variables
but it's it's cold that this is
something that seems to capture a lot of
the variance that occurs and what you
want to do when you're making a model is
put in the data that's most has the
largest leverage and ignore the data
that doesn't have any leverage and
models principally we don't do that when
we make we put in everything including
the kitchen sink so this is kind of a
refreshing way of looking at it alright
so I think we'll skip over that quickly
and go on the idea that we worked on was
the observation that the light that was
coming from read reflected by the canopy
in the near infrared seem to correlate
quite well with then it was coming off
fluorescence if we were looking at full
canopies and this is sorting out pixels
by their normalized difference
vegetation index so when that vegetation
index is high you get a really high
correlation with the reflectance and as
it goes down to less vegetated pixels of
course that correlation goes away so we
thought well let's just multiply the
total near phred reflectance times the
NDVI and see what happens and this is
SIF and that product they fall in line
really nicely and the thing that's
really nice about this even though it's
kind of a derived product we've got that
at 300 meters resolution 300 meters
ground resolution and we have it from
1980 to present so we can now look at
flux ice with something that looks a
little bit like solar news fluorescence
it isn't exactly the same
has some of the same properties this is
just looking at this that correlated
with some global models again just the
the annual NRV sum and the GPP modelled
so they it captures a lot of the
variability in the biosphere all by
itself what we're looking at is
essentially the the normalized
difference vegetation index is this
error this reflectance here this green
is the reflectance of a leaf and you
look at it it looks at the ratio of this
band to and band for the difference
between those two over the sum of those
and the this is a spectrum of soil you
can see that there's some slope there
but not nearly as much so that is that
vegetation index for the soil if you
were looking at soil would be very low
vegetation index you're looking at at
the at a vegetated area would be very
high and what we're if you think of it
the the light that's coming off of say a
mix pixel like this you have a very low
NDVI of the light that's coming up from
the soil but if that's coming off from a
leaf it has a very high if you multiply
the total times this ratio the NDVI this
index the NDVI you essentially get
something it's all coming from the leaf
it's going to be high and generic bread
that's coming off the canopy is going to
be off the plant and it's going to vary
pretty much by how much a fraction of
light that's coming out of the system is
that's coming from the leaf it's
actually analogous to the way that we're
measuring fluorescence
we're just determining how much of the
in there
red light is coming off leaves and
multiplying that times the total and
that gives us an index that's kind of
like the fluorescence and this is what
you see if we just take the total NIR
and compare it this is four pixels so
this is actually for all the all the
land surface so this is just the total
near-infrared coming out and you can see
it's scattered there's some some
indication that there's something there
but if you just multiply it by the NIR
the NDVI you get just nice correlation
because it throws away all these
excellents that are influenced by clouds
or soil or other things interfere and if
you just take the these are flux sites
now if you take the say a hundred or so
flux sites and look at the annual GPP
some and the some of the this NRB some
other things that we can analyze it
looks it's actually quite an improvement
over other approaches that been used in
the past and one of the things that
really we found very interesting of this
is that if we took this na RV you would
think that if you took that and
multiplied it by the light did improve
things but it actually makes it worse I
and we think that what's going on what
we're finding is that there isn't the na
RV has most of the environmental
correlates that have normally thought to
drive photosynthesis already kind of
work into it and when you add another
one or add one that's already in it you
just add the noise so we're very
interested in it that from that point of
view because that means we we have a
that a system is growing a canopy which
has
some I think we'll just skip over these
except to show you the canapes are very
diverse plants grow those canopies under
genetic and environmental control they
have very different properties in the
way they transport radiation but the way
that they reflect near-infrared
radiation seems to have a lot of
information about how they actually are
function and I we're really interested
in it from the point of view of
understanding the biology of this
control so first before stopping just
mentioned that there are a couple of
other things that are really interesting
in this if this is an area where we're
looking at an area in the Amazon with
two different remote sensing products
one's better cloud filtered than the
other the better remote sensing product
has a tighter correlation so we can
improve this by getting better remote
sensing this is a c3 soybean crop this
is a corn crop same floor you can see
that there's a big difference
as you'd expect because of c4
photosynthesis things like that that can
also be put into to improve this system
it works well monthly and does as well
as the best models all by itself and
it's a pretty good job of simulating
global photosynthesis and somewhat up
there thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah actually the oceans are easier
because there's no no substantial
reflectance in the near-infrared so
they've been using it for some time to
do fluorescence the biggest most of the
work has been done looking at things
like nutrient limitation there's a new
satellite that has just come online
called Romi that allows you to do red
fluorescence red light gets out of the
ocean the near-infrared light that we're
working with the ocean is black in that
range so you can see coastal blooms and
things like that we haven't worked very
much with that at this point but I think
it's going to be useful any effect of
the polarization of skylight changes
during the day
yeah well certainly the reflectance
remote sensing is it is there there are
there have been satellites put up to
look at polarization of the light I
there's all also in effect I mean the
the specular reflectance off of the
leaves is polarized so you know if light
strikes the epidermis and then it's
reflected back like a mirror
that's for reflectance a real problem
because it doesn't carry the this signal
of the vegetation and they've been able
to eliminate that bipolar by looking at
the polarization
there is also the satellite that
measures the oco-2 satellite it changes
its orientation as it goes through the
from north to south from pole to pole
and because of polarization and I don't
understand the spectroscopy of that
maybe maybe you do they do that they
rotate the position of the slit because
of the polarization effect so it is it
is important but I don't I don't
understand yeah with a region that has
water limitation throat or so I assume
aids close to 2 into believe how well if
they I know we we don't have an awful
lot of measurements where we have
regulated control of water availability
at this point we we have drought
episodes what we see is that droughts
almost invariably result in lower
fluorescence all right it could be we
see that droughts and leaves have less
fluorescence but not a huge effect it
could be that there is an additional
effect due to leaf dropping leaf curling
leaf obsession and things like that that
happened consistent or simultaneously
with the drought which interesting also
has to do with just shedding light just
as the the the non photochemical
quenching does the plan
so responding to drought by absorbing
less light and letting less of that
light get to the reaction centers
because it's then because of the
limitation of water become less able to
use that light chemistry it's a really
good question i1 what you tend to see
and you we'd have to look for for small
areas that are I think there are some
sites that are in the Corn Belt but in
forests for example that we could look
at and figure that out
my my expectation is that the whole
thing is pretty much limited by the the
season and the environment and but
that's for crops the productivity is
squished into a very narrow window and
for forests it kind of gets spread out
and I wouldn't be surprised if they tend
to be more the same if you add it all up
over the year but I don't have a good
answer yeah to use this yeah well we you
see a very substantial change in the
reflectance of the planet in these
visible wavelengths visible and
near-infrared wavelengths I it's been
suggested as a way of looking for for
photosynthetic pigments on other planets
I think the more likely way that we'll
get to that in the near future is
looking at the light that's that gets
through the atmosphere as the planet
transits across the star but
yeah I think it's worth a shot certainly
worth thinking about yes that's a good
good point what we do in almost all of
our models of plans of radiation
transport for example our system models
as we we have all kinds of very
elaborate descriptions of the water
relations and the physiology of the
plant and then we put in an arbitrary
function for the way that light is
absorbed by the leaves and that can be
spiracle or a rectifier but people have
avoided dealing with the explicit
radiative transport of the canopies and
our work is saying that that is really
important and we aren't going to get
photosynthesis right until we do that
and how and understand how that relates
to how enzymatic capacity is also
distributed among those leaves so yeah
and the other thing that's I think
really interesting about this is that
the work kind of suggests that
photosynthesis isn't that strongly
limited by physiology it's more limited
by the amount of canopy and the
structure of the canopy that's made and
we're not dealing with that at all
in modeling or in modeling newer systems
so that's that's what I mean by it's
wrong it's wrong to say no but everybody
tacit assumptions about the nature of
the photon itself or the nature of light
itself in coming up with your models
I well probably we have but a and and
this whole thing about they the thing on
the Sun and they linking to the
chlorophyll that that sort of thing it's
something I made up
just recently all right and I've ordered
a couple of physicists asked you know
it's this really off-the-wall or it's
about weight weighted way to explain it
and they said yeah I don't like the you
know the vocabulary using but it seems
about right but if it would be yeah good
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu